you know suga's always been solid with
me
you know so
um
you know he was like he gave me his
blessing
which i thought was like oh
it must be right you know suge was just
like well you know whatever you do
corrupt keep your business good you know
what i'm saying and you know i think
that's what you should do if that's what
you want to do you know you i'm all with
you man
you know keep your business up to par
you know what i'm saying and so he
didn't he didn't
react the way
that you know
we i i would assume that era of suge
knight it wouldn't have been the nicest
reaction
but he never
came at me like that
ever even when i was a kid
never was this guy that people paint the
picture of
yeah i was going to say like you you
were around shook for the better part of
you know 10 plus years right so we we
hear a lot about suge and then i'll talk
to people who
were around him or who are close with
him and they'll say well you know shug's
not
i'm sure that there's a side to head
sugar was like a father figure
i mean he taught
told us the game
showed us the game
it was
a lot of things he kept out
you know what i'm saying didn't tell us
about but
you know uh when you're moving that fast
you know you don't
get to do to say everything or do
everything
what he did
teaches shaped our lives gave us a
career he believed in us
invested in us time energy and
financially you know
and um
you know he was he supported us 100
you know what i'm saying
uh
you just hear all these stories like
people were getting beat up at the
studio all the time or there was just a
lot of crazy [ __ ] going on like
you know however many documentaries that
have ever come out there's always that
side of the death row story that we hear
about right never heard none of us were
actually i hear about the good parts
right and there's a lot you know there's
two sides of every corner right just
there's two sides to every coin big
homie and you know
uh when it comes to suge that's the only
side that people
want you to see
it's more exciting